in fact there's a much better way to
maintain ongoing action toward a goal
that also involves visualization
but it turns out it's not about
visualizing success it's about
visualizing failure the balsaes lab and
other labs have looked at whether or not
people make progress toward goals of
different types
whether or not they're thinking about
the goal
they're thinking about that goal line
and what they want to achieve that
long-term goal and all the wonderful
things associated with it or whether or
not they are thinking about all the ways
in which they could fail and root to
that goal right this is not typically
what we are encouraged to do typically
we are told don't imagine failure push
failure out of your mind only focus on
success you know fake it till you make
it or it's a phrase that i absolutely
hate frankly because it's not even clear
what that means and it's not even clear
what the ethical form of that is i think
it means continue despite any anxiety or
fear that things won't work out but if
you look at the literature
the scientific literature
what the balsaedas lab and other labs
have shown is that there's a near
doubling near doubling in the
probability of reaching one's goal
if you focus
routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action b
and instead therefore you take action c
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though i realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just fitness
fitness goals and physical goals are a
very concrete thing that we can all get
on the same page about because they're
related to actions let's say somebody
that sets a goal of
running five miles four times a week
minimum and as many as seven four times
a minimum before 8am okay in a previous
podcast on habits i talked about the
benefits of not necessarily setting
specific times that one will do things
but setting time blocks that one will do
things so you say before 8 am you're
going to run five miles
and that's going to happen up to seven
days a week okay
one version of this would be okay sit
back in a chair and think about how
great you're going to feel and look if
you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything is going to your blood
markers of lipids etc are going to
improve okay fine that's the
visualization goal
of visualizing the endpoint turns out
that is far less effective and maybe
even counterproductive compared to
thinking about
what's going to happen if you don't do
this
the negative health outcomes that are
going to occur the disappointment you're
going to have in yourself the fact that
you're going to wait until 7 30 that's
not long enough for many people to run
five miles you got to put it on your
shoes it could be pouring rain or even
hailing or snowing outside and now
you're not going outside unless you're
somebody who's particularly motivated to
do that okay so foreshadowing failure
turns out to be the best way to motivate
toward goal pursuit in fact as i
mentioned before there's a near doubling
in the likelihood that people will reach
goals of any kind when they're
constantly thinking about how bad it's
going to be if they fail if we think
back to the neural circuit associated
with assessing value in our goal
pursuits this makes perfect sense the
amygdala that center of the brain that's
involved in anxiety and fear and worry
well the amygdala is one of the four
core components of our goal setting and
goal pursuit circuitry and there's no
bypassing that there is no one listening
to this or watching this whose amygdala
is not involved in their goal setting
and goal pursuit behavior and so while
i'd love to be able to tell you that all
you should think about is rainbows and
puppies and all the wonderful rewarding
things that are going to happen when you
achieve your goals
the truth is you should be thinking
mainly about how bad it's really going
to get if you don't do it how
disappointing yourself you're going to
feel how
it will negatively impact you if not in
the immediate term in the long term if
indeed your goal is to reach your goal
so
i want to emphasize that i'm not
interested in encouraging people to
flagellate themselves i'm encouraging
people to
achieve their goals and it turns out the
best way to do that is by foreshadowing
failure and the more specific you can
get by writing down or thinking about or
talking about how bad it will be if you
don't achieve your goals the more likely
you are to achieve those goals need
motivation what's your top 10
with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best dr andrew huberman and my
take on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy
rule number two listen to your gut i
really believe that we all have some
superpower that reflects maybe this is a
bit of a scientific explanation that
reflects the fact that our biology
is tilted in some direction people often
things about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or i'm not a good
athlete or i'm whatever but
it's also tilted in the direction of
something really special so like when i
was a kid of that age
i was fascinated by animals i was just
like my and so
had i learned to listen to that more i
used to hide my interest in animals
because i thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like i didn't play the
guitar in college i didn't surf i always
like like i can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know
but i think that kind of leaning that
kind of tilt towards like huh like
that's me like you resonate with
something and i'm not the first to say
this i think robert greene also said
this like there's a
adults will often remember back to a
time where they interacted with
something sometimes it's an object or
sometimes it's an experience and it just
felt so good like it kind of drew you in
i would tell your young listeners to
and viewers to really
pay attention to that
it can seem almost trivial like it's
rarely about the thing you're looking at
or the thing you're doing but sometimes
it's the sensation of running sometimes
it's it's it's the sensation of
viewing seeing something or hearing
something because there's a hint there
and it's the it's not really about what
you're looking at or you're doing it's
that feeling like learn it that feeling
is your compass like that's your true
north because that's the feeling you
want to get to
for to find
you know the mate for your life the you
know the partner for your life the the
career track and over time you're gonna
pivot right i mean you're not gonna get
it on the first try
i eventually my story is science started
there it told me right there i
felt it in that conversation with my dad
and then my compass was all over the
place and spinning and eventually it's
it's come back
i found it but getting in get in touch
with that feeling and if this seems at
all abstract i would do it as an
experiment
i would sit in a chair
and i would think about something you
don't like
like really don't like and i would pay
attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body i'm not a
very somatic person i'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body i've always felt like my emotions
were my head so when people talk about
like their emotions in their
other places i'm just like
i don't get it
but i would encourage them to think
about that and then i would encourage
them to think about something they
really like
it could be roller coasters could be
music could be
get specific and to get in touch with
that feeling and that feeling is your
guide
that feeling is your compass
because the nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will orient toward the things that
it's best equipped to do
it really well
and i really animals do this naturally
my bulldog costello never tries to be
a different kind of dog he never fetched
once
first time i threw the ball he walked to
the ball he sat down with the ball he
destroyed the ball because that's what
bulldogs do you know throw to a
retriever they bring it back because the
brain of the retriever is wired to feel
good by retrieving yeah and the brain of
the bulldog is good to feel good by
being horizontal
with and pulling on things with their
they like to tug
so i think humans we're so we're similar
enough but we're different in the sense
that you have something installed in you
that feels right
and getting in touch with that feeling
is key and you're not and i should tell
that there's you're not going to get it
right away this is a practice you learn
like shooting basketballs or or math you
do it over and over so that but if you
get started young at eight or nine oh my
goodness great and if you do it when
you're 12 or even if you're 60 and you
do this
you'll find that pretty soon you start
steering in these directions i i do
believe it's a nervous i think our it's
a neural there's a real physical
substrate for this it's not mysticism
rule number three expand your vision
both those things
breathing and vision also run in reverse
meaning if we change our pattern of
breathing we change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bidirectional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands
but as well it runs in both directions
if we expand our view of the world
literally force our our visual field or
just it's very easy actually you can do
it no matter where you are right now if
you just try and expand your visual
field not by looking around or moving
your head or eyes but by trying to see
yourself in the environment that you're
in so you literally dilate your view so
you could see the ceiling in the floor
and the walls if you're inside or if
you're outdoors seeing as big an
aperture of your visual field or your
visual environment as possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal state towards stress
this is why when you go to a
vista or you view a horizon it's very
relaxing because you naturally go into
panoramic vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at a computer
or a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal state
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or obsession or fascination but
the important thing to realize is that
both vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal state of mind and body and
it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says drives
changes in our breathing and our vision
but our breathing and our vision can
also drive changes in our internal state
and so that article in scientific
american
was a discussion about how we can
leverage the visual system and the
respiration the breathing system in
order to take control over our internal
state because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal state determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel
like we're having a hard time falling
asleep or having a hard time focusing
for instance it also determines how we
batch time how we analyze
where we are in the world in terms of
our lifespan a good example this would
be when we are very stressed we find
slice time this is why when people are
in a car accident or something they
might report that things were in slow
motion they're actually your frame rate
increases
whereas when you're very relaxed your
frame rate slows down and when we are
relaxed we get so-called perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or i can place the stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to how our nervous system
works is that we are constantly placing
our experience both our immediate and
past
experience as well as our anticipation
of the future into some sort of larger
context and our visual system literally
how we are viewing the world at that
moment
dictates how we create perspective in
terms of states of mind sounds a little
bit abstract but it's actually it boils
right down to optics of the eye and very
concrete things like how you move your
eyes and how you view the world rule
number four control your dopamine how do
you get motivated well one way to do
that is if you are good at subjectively
attaching
dopamine to the pursuit just knowing
okay i really am hungry for this i'm
just i'm going to tell myself that you
know making you know
making it one percent of the way is a
success and i'm going to keep going and
i'm going to keep ratcheting on and
that's great if you can do that but for
people that can't do that understanding
this relationship with the pleasure pain
balance can be more powerful just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier of the
whole process of pursuing more dopamine
and then the other aspect of it
is that any time that we're leaning into
action
you know it has the
possibility of being an amplifying
process or a depleting process
and the key to that is making sure that
you're balancing the dopamine and
epinephrine systems you know epinephrine
being this molecule of universal
currency of energy output
could be out of hate or could be out of
love epinephrine doesn't care and
actually dopamine doesn't care none of
these systems care about us they just
work underneath our underneath our
conscious control but when you start to
understand that
hitting the gas pedal is great but
hitting the gas pedal and then coming
off the gas pedal a little bit
you can kind of sit in a more relaxed
rpm actually allows you to go much
further i think that people
leaning into action is terrific i always
say you can either be back on your heels
flat-footed or forward center of mass
the best situation is actually to be
right upright but just know that you can
be forward center of mass at any point
and you know that to take it back to sex
and reproduction because it's a salient
example the arc of of sex is very
interesting because when you think about
autonomic arousal it turns out that the
the arousal stage of sex actually
involves release of dopamine but is what
we call parasympathetic dominant it
actually has to be relaxed enough
in order to occur okay everyone can read
between the lines on this
orgasm is actually
a
i want to say full blown it's a it's a
it is a sympathetic
nervous system driven response it's
identical to the stress system it's
driven by the same neural circuits as
stress
and then what comes afterward
the parasympathetic system goes back up
again it's that deep relaxation so why
do i say this not to talk about sex to
be
you know to to serve as a highlighter
but rather our species arrived here
because of this dance between arousal
and relaxation arousal and relaxation
and one thing we can say for sure about
every human being that's alive now is
that their parents at least once
mastered this dance of relaxed but not
and excited but not too excited then
really excited and then relaxed that
dance was mastered by all of our parents
and that's what delivered us here to
some extent and so i
what this means is that all the neural
circuits from the ones that led to our
conception to the ones that lead to us
pursuing goals have this
balance this almost like a like a seesaw
right there's activation and calm
activation and calm and it's that
dynamic process that's important to
master in every endeavor so we use sex
as an example but in pursuit of goals
you have to learn how to pursue
short-term goals
and like the goals within the day make a
cup of coffee and go and long-term goals
and when i said dopamine is what's
setting the
your time perception it's an interval
timer
what you're saying is it's like the two
marshmallow experiment done at stanford
def defer the dopamine
and actually
if you can turn the waiting into the
dopamine and then
you can extend out the reward for you
know waiting for the second marshmallow
15 minutes later etc etc and there are
many many examples of this in the
psychology and neuroscience literature
and i would say finally in 2020 we
finally as a field got a clear idea of
how dopamine is really working because
before it was all about
work dopamine hit right sex gives you a
double when you hit the internet gives
you a dopamine what we didn't realize is
that repeated engagement with these
things leads to dopamine depletion
and that the pain and pleasure balance
is always at work
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five be optimistic the
beliefs are attached to a set of rewards
so
what now the dopamine system is
exceedingly powerful because dopamine
is
is a kind of a dumb molecule it has no
brain of its own it's just a it's just a
molecule right it's just a chemical but
when dopamine is released in our brain
we
first of all it tends to orient us
towards
goals in the outside environment it's
the it's the molecule not just a reward
but of motivation and when we release
dopamine we tend to see the world in
terms of external goals
and so you can imagine now if there's a
process built up inside us where our
thoughts
are causing
dopamine release and dopamine is shaping
what we see as rewards what we perceive
as rewards
that can be
wonderful or terrible depending on how
that's harnessed so let me understand
this when we have
dopamine
[Music]
uh triggered in our body
it's attached to
because it's attached to some type of
belief we're going to continue to say
this feels good that's right so let me
keep thinking this way and viewing the
world this in this way because it's
going to keep making me feel good that's
right physically that's right wow even
if it's
fact or not fact right scientifically
true or not or harmful to other people
or harmful to yourself if it makes you
feel good you might stick to that belief
that's right so a good example with
dopamine is it with any time thinking
about science and neuroscience in
particular thinking at the extremes can
be kind of useful so people who are very
depressed who see no possibility in the
world who if you talk to a depressed
person every response they give is going
to be but it's not going to work out it
doesn't they are absolutely certain that
things are going to turn out bad and
there's a benefit
for having that belief they're
entrenched in it they may actually be
rewarding that somewhat although
typically depressed states have very low
dopamine
at the opposite extreme is mania when
people are in a manic phase dopamine is
very high we know this and they see
possibility everywhere and there's
certain things are going to work out
they they will spend money they don't
have they'll create relationships they
don't have time and energy for they will
overdo everything and so somewhere in
the middle is this healthy range where
we're where we realize that how we view
the world is shaping the release of
these chemicals and i do believe this
happens when we have positive thoughts
we we get a lift if we if we can get a
lift from our positive thoughts and then
dopamine itself puts us in
relationship with the outside world such
that we view the outside world as having
more possibility that is going to put us
into forward momentum
they're good
there are a lot of studies to support
that when dopamine is low we tend to see
very little possibility in the world
and so a positive thought
triggers
forward movement potentially yes yeah so
positive thinking which a lot of people
will say well that's just positive
thinking it doesn't work
some people say be positive think
positive others say well it doesn't work
but with science i'm hearing you say it
gives you a little bit of a lift
absolutely the the key with positive
thinking it is that it has to be honest
it it can't be i've already won you know
i don't have an olympic gold medal if i
could tell myself i'm going to get one
tomorrow but i just don't have the
skills so that's not going to release
dopamine in my system how do you know
it's honest if you're in a depressed
state and you don't believe
that
you are actually better off than where
you're at the key is to attach the so
one thing to understand is that dopamine
release in the brain is always
subjective
there's no experience that that says uh
that has unique domain over dopamine
release that will only allow dopamine
release so
if it's very subjective so if i say to
myself
i'm going to
get into the process of doing something
we have a new year coming up so there'll
be a lot of resolutions soon
the
it's not a if you attach the dopamine
release to the process of effort or goal
setting itself you'll have more energy
to be in effort and then if you can
attach dopamine release to the belief
that you're at least heading in the
right direction you'll have more energy
to keep going in the right direction
people make the mistake of thinking
that
the
the positive thought process should be
attached to the finish line
it's not about thinking of already one
it's not about being delusional it's
about thinking that your training is
going to take you to the finish line and
so it's about moving that mental horizon
in more close but more closely and then
triggering some sort of positive
internal representation of what you're
doing meaning thinking positive and
people this is usually where i get
stopped and people say wait but it
sounds so subjective tell me exactly how
to do it but here's the keyboard it's
it's supposed to be subjective
this is for you right yeah everyone
needs to figure out what allows them to
continue to be in forward momentum what
allows them to constrain the world of
possibilities
and to go after goals and how often to
self-reward
because
but the key is the self-worth because if
you start only pursuing external rewards
that's when you are no longer in control
of your dopamine system because you're
relying on actually something physically
happening in the physical world not
internal that's right and let's be
really really honest and burst the the
bubble that i feel like should have been
burst a long time ago which is yes
everybody including me it is possible
that you can do everything and still
fail no one wants to say that but the
way that you insure against that is to
attach reward to the effort process
because the dopamine molecule
creates a sense of certainty and you're
not trying to create certainty about the
final outcome you're trying to create
certainty only about the next outcome
that's enroute to the final outcome the
next action
yes and so people set out with oh i'm
gonna i'm gonna write the great american
novel or i'm going to um you know get
the ipo and of course that's an
important you need to have a sense of
what the finish line would actually look
like but the more that one can attach
this subjective release of dopamine
process to the intermediate steps
through positive thinking and action
positive thinking and action
the the higher that probability goes
toward in science we say there's a
probability of zero to one the higher
that probability goes to one which is
certainty now
everyone knows in the back of their mind
that there is no absolute certainty when
i hear about you know athletes or
fighters i was certain i was going to
win we all know that there's a
.000 doubt
in everybody right .00 whatever that is
now for some people
they
might be able to push that number way
way out but
certainty about outcome is actually a
form of delusion
certainty about romania yeah that's
right certain that's right you see this
in mania and that's why people start
engaging in behavior
online this is going to happen that's
right the silver lining in this is that
when you create certainty about outcomes
you know you can control
you take over this neurobiological
system and you create almost certainty
that you will complete the process to
the end goal
perfectly rule number six balance pain
and pleasure understanding that pain and
pleasure in this really dynamic balance
can also help us which in the following
way
any pain that you feel the longer day
the less sleep the the kind of agony
that things aren't working that power
outlet doesn't work or the internet is
slow whatever it is
the amount of pleasure that you will
eventually experience
is directly relation related excuse me
to how much pain you experience so we
know this from actually what nowadays
would be considered quite barbaric and
unethical experiments where they would
give people electrical shocks
and they would measure their response
and then they'd say we're going to
increase it we're going to increase it
eventually they get to the point where a
slight shock that was previously very
painful actually evokes a sense of
pleasure
now you couldn't do these experiments
anymore these are not the experiments i
do in my lab
and these are older experiments but
for instance i and this has been
discussed in scientific research papers
giving somebody a like a 10-minute ice
bath for instance or even a three-minute
ice bath or a one-minute ice bath it's
quite painful but there was a study from
the university of prague uh european
journal physiology showed that after a
painful ice bath stimulus
the amount of dopamine release goes up
for two and a half hours to 250 percent
above baseline and that's not because
the ice bath itself evokes dopamine
release a lot of people think oh cold
water of ox dopamine release no pain
evokes dopamine release after the pain
is over yesterday i tweaked my back
because i do this stupid thing every few
years the same stupid thing and it's
really painful and then you just
remember all the ways in which you can't
move around i was like standing up this
morning i'm like ah and just walking is
so painful as the pain has started to
dissipate you get a little bit of a high
right you get a little bit of a euphoria
that's dopamine because of the the
degree of pain you experienced
previously predicts how much pleasure so
when you start a company down in the
dregs and you're shoveling again
that's beautiful because that means that
the win that you achieve
is going to be as good or greater than
the one you had previously in your case
with quest and so we go back to this
example the person that's not motivated
that can't get off the couch that's
doesn't want to do anything well this is
the problem we remember the rad
experiment they are effectively the rat
with no dopamine but they can still
achieve some sense of pleasure by
consuming excess calories by consuming
social media and look i'm not judging i
do this stuff too right scrolling social
media if you've ever scrolled social
media and you're like i don't even know
why i'm doing this it doesn't really
feel that good
and i can remember a time where you'd
see something it's just so cool or you
see something online i remember this
when ted talks first came out i was like
this is amazing these are some at least
some of them are really smart people
sharing really cool insights and then
now that they're like a gazillion
ted talks i remember spending a winter
in my office at when i was a junior
professor cleaning my office finally
and binging ted talks in the background
thinking this is a good use of my time
pretty soon they all sucked to me i was
like this isn't good so what you need to
do is stop watching dead docs for a
while
wait and then they become interesting
again and that's this pain pleasure
balance and so for people that aren't
feeling motivated the problem is they're
not motivated but they're getting just
enough or excess sustenance so they're
getting the little mild hits of opioid
it becomes an opioid system and if you
think about the opioid drugs as opposed
to dopamine dopaminergic drugs
dopaminergic drugs make people rabid for
everything you know drugs of abuse like
cocaine and amphetamine make people
incredibly outward directed or they
hardly notice anything except what they
want more of more more more it's very
it's bad
because those drugs trigger so much
dopamine release that they become the
reward it's very circular the only the
drug can give that much dopamine nothing
they could pursue would give them as
much dopamine as the drug itself
so there's that and then there's the
kind of opioid like effects
of constantly indulging oneself with
social media or with video games or with
with food or with anything to the point
where it no longer evokes the motivation
and craving and this is really the new
evolution of the understanding of
dopamine in neuroscience which is that
dopamine itself is not the reward it's
the build-up to the reward and the
reward has more of a kind of opioid
bliss-like property which itself is not
bad if it's endogenous released from
within but when we can just sit there
like the like the rat with no dopamine
gorging ourselves with pleasures so to
speak what you end up with is somebody
that feels really unmotivated and those
pleasures no longer work to tickle those
feel good circuits and so there's no
reason for them to go out and pursue
anything and that's a pretty dark
picture so the the keys are
to pursue rewards but understand that
the pursuit is actually the reward if
you want to have repeated
wins okay you the celebration has to be
less than the pursuit and that's hard
for some people to do
they you know they it's got to be that
your celebration is slightly less
dopaminergic
it can be very reflective you can be in
gratitude those are other
neurotransmitter systems but you don't
want to be on that high as you celebrate
the win
you want to be
trickling out your dopamine
regularly until you pursue things rule
number seven avoid distractions
previously i told you that it's great to
foreshadow failure that that's a great
way to get your system into a state of
activation i also told you that you want
to set goals that are challenging but
possible and again here i'm paraphrasing
from the work of emily balcetis i want
to be very clear
there are a few other things that one
can do in order to bias the likelihood
that you will succeed in trying to
achieve your goals first of all
limit your options
trying to pursue too many goals at once
can definitely be counterproductive now
i realize that life is complicated
we all have multiple goals that we're
trying to pursue but if we have
particular goals that are important to
us we have to be careful to not get
distracted by other goals and many
people run into this problem so setting
one or two or maybe three major goals
for a given year is going to be more
than enough for most people and is
actually going to be challenging for
most people now of course we have daily
goals and monthly goals and yearly goals
but if we have big lofty goals we need
to be careful not to contaminate our
mental space and our visual space with
too many goals and why do i say visual
goals well
what various department stores and
supermarkets have discovered
is that the
greater the number of things in our
visual attention the more that we can
draw our attention and our goals off a
line of pursuit what does that mean well
let's think about in the practical
context this has actually been done big
department stores have figured out that
if they stock their shelves chock a
block with many many options of food or
clothing items or objects or anything
like that people simply buy more stuff
people are very prone to
orienting their attention to whatever's
in front of them you put a lot of stuff
in front of them their attention drifts
you put fewer things in front of them
their attention is more narrow
in a later episode we'll talk about
designing a workspace that's optimized
on the basis of this it doesn't mean
being in a room with nothing except just
your desk and a computer doesn't have to
be that sparse but visual sparseness
actually can help us orient our focus
and our behavior when we have a lot of
things in our visual environment or a
lot of things in our cognitive
environment it's the same thing and so
if you're going to try and pursue a
fitness goal a relationship goal an
academic goal and a long-term life
financial goal all at once that's four
things and you're going to have to come
up with systems that allow you to
isolate those goals
in a very rigid way rule number eight
raise your alertness
if you want to learn and change your
brain as an adult there has to be a high
level of focus and engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
because so focus and intensity and that
kind of the the goggins phenotype right
i think gog is now a noun a verb and a
pronoun right it's like it's amazing so
if you're going to goggins this process
we need to do is you need to regardless
of how agitated you feel you have to
lean in
and focus extremely hard now the reason
for that is that there's a neurochemical
norepinephrine also called adrenaline
same thing that's released in the brain
and body most people back off at that
point because they feel this agitation
but we have to remember that that
neuroadrenaline was designed to get us
into movement that's the purpose of
noradrenaline to take us out of
stillness and into movement and then the
other thing we have to do is we have to
take that elevated level of alertness
and we have to focus it and there's a
second neuromodulator called
acetylcholine
which is secreted from this little
structure in the base of the forebrain
when we visually focus on something or
in the case of maybe if you're doing
auditory learning when you focus with
your auditory attention neuroplasticity
is triggered when urgency and focus
combine
acetylcholine is released for the
aficionados out there it's called the
nucleus basalis but that doesn't matter
there's a little compartment of neurons
in the base of your forebrain that
doesn't like to release acetylcholine on
a regular basis it's a it's greedy it's
greedy and it doesn't want to use that
with your child it'll rain your brain
with acetylcholine but as an adult 30 40
updates why is that
because
you know mother nature designed us to
learn what we need to learn and then do
that reproduce and die i mean not to be
you know how rude dark about it but i
always say evolution is not about us
it's about the offspring yeah right 100
percent you know it's and it's not even
about them it's about their offspring
exactly never ends we are being
manipulated from the inside yes i mean
that's what it you know kind of drew me
in neurobiology is that all these
complex things you see in the world
it's all internal
so
you know if you get urgency it can come
from
let's use david as a he's a shining
example of this right you can sit there
and just ramp up your level of urgency
through purely psychological means
you could take an ice bath you could do
high-intensity breathing anything that
brings your level of alertness up rule
number nine play with intense focus
there are other things that if it's a
physical skill that you're trying to
learn
as opposed to just a mental skill then
there's a whole kingdom of things that
are fun for instance if it's a physical
skill you want to generate as many
repetitions as you safely can per unit
time so if you say i'm going to learn
dance you want a ball machine if you're
playing tennis exactly you literally
want to generate repetitions and in
particular you want to generate failures
every time you you give a bad serve
playing tennis oh yeah
that activates the circuits for focus
and alertness for the next
yeah it's true that's right so when
you're losing that's right
so so that and a lot of people don't
like failures and so they back away from
it so remember the nervous system will
only change if you give it a reason to
do that and the other one that's kind of
an interesting twist on this is the way
the nervous system is wired is it wants
to pass off
all of its work to circuits that are
reflexive as much as it can you don't
think about walking anymore because you
learned how to walk but when you were
learning you were very focused on sure
one of the things that can set the stage
for more plasticity overall is when you
disrupt the vestibular or the balance
system
it does appear that whenever we are
physically off balance the brain is
primed to pay attention
and the mil the chemical milieu is such
that it can actually rewire itself
faster and whereas i think the 90s and
2000s brought out a lot of important
work on saying hey
a exercise of aerobic type or maybe even
weight training can create um
neuroplasticity
it was that was great but it wasn't
directed enough it didn't say well what
kind of exercise yeah and what will get
me even more plasticity and so there are
some basal things about heart rate and
blood flow etc but anything that
involves balance
or coordination
it's incredible how fast the brain can
learn so things like dance martial arts
a real sport not just exercising and i'm
not no disrespect to the the ex i'm more
of a just an exerciser than a sport guy
but
if you're
40 50 60 80 whatever learning a new
physical skill
we know is tremendously powerful for
opening up neuroplasticity broadly
so some people will even leverage this
where
after they finish some physical skill
learning or something they might take a
20-minute nap and then they might read
yeah they might try something so when we
see these people and then i've been
learning surfing i'm like 60 years old
perfect so singular and i'm like
exactly
exactly i learned started learning
tennis when i was 45 and it's really
a challenge because it's not automatic
and i have to really focus and be
present well these and these individual
cases are are not necessarily the place
to hang our hat completely but for
instance the great physicist richard
feynman he was well known for learning
bongo drums in the six when he was in
well it was in the 60s but in his 60s
then he became a quite accomplished um
painter later in life and you know his
whole thing was
approach all of these things from a
standpoint of play
with intense focus yeah and i think the
play element is key because the play
element keeps the agitation in check so
that when you're stepping on your
partner's feet trying to learn how to
dance or you're failing miserably it it
can frustration is a real thing and so i
think that the element of playfulness
some people call it beginner's mind but
i think
that should be the anchor point to
return to and people that maintain
curiosity or i should say that cultivate
curiosity and that cultivate a sense of
play and willingness to take on new
vestibular
experiences of all things
they
show very
they show remarkable plasticity into
their late life and i think that
it all comes back to this thing that the
brain won't change unless
something changes in the weather of the
brain the overall milieu has to say oh
wait everything that's about to happen
is different yeah otherwise why would it
change and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
just keep going there are other goals
that are very different last time we
talked you were learning spanish yeah
still learning yeah still learning and
there's a and there's a little bit more
friction there because it's challenging
it takes more effort to lean in because
you when you don't already know how to
do something it's a very different goal
pursuit
right sort of like so if i already have
my business and i've been running it for
a few years you know certain practices
of how to get to where you've been
that's right and you're thinking how do
i double my business that's right it's
different than i'm trying to learn a
whole new skill goal right you already
know how to start forage for water as
opposed to you're some young calf or
some animal that needs to learn how to
walk
right so
you so i think
you know one big goal
of the sort that um you know we don't
actually have the skill set yet we're
not even aware that of what we need in
order to accomplish it per year seems
like a pretty good goal to me so
learning entirely new language or an
entirely new physical skill
but with any long-term goal the problem
is
don't focus on the destination that's
right well so you have to move the
horizon in
but you have to remember there's that
one little pitfall that cul-de-sac that
i described where you'll tell people
this year i'm going to do blank and if
they reward you enough you might not do
it remember if you get enough dopamine
it's amazing i'm so happy you're doing
that congratulations and you say i know
i can do it and then you don't you sort
of lose the incentive to do it
so some a lot's been made out of making
goals public is it is it better to make
them public or not well so this is this
is a question i don't know i think that
in my case it has
for me telling people
several people that i'm going to do
something because i will work very hard
to avoid
uh humidity
um but i tend to do that with things i
really want to do anyway but there's a
strong fear element like i'm afraid to
do this or i'm i'm kind of anxious about
doing this so i'll tell people
and then i'm like okay now i'm committed
yeah you gotta do this you gotta do it
now and i tell people that i'm certain
they're gonna give me a hard time yeah
that's just my name right um and i'm not
trying to prove them wrong i'm just
trying to make sure that they don't have
any ground to stand on yeah and that's
how i do it i think for
some people
the
continuation of what they're already
doing if it's feeling like a lot of work
it's feeling exceedingly challenging and
they're like oh my god another year of
this another five years of that
i think that's when you have to move the
horizon in really close i think a lot of
people right now are feeling back on
their heels because 2020 was such a
trying year for a lot of people
so everyone many people are
recalibrating what's possible although
many people are feeling expansion and
they're really going to go forward full
steam so i think
continuing in pursuits that we already
have some degree of mastery over and
thinking about where could i notch that
up another two or three percent i think
that's incredibly valuable i think that
provides a lot of value to the
individual to their families and to
society really because a two percent
improvement of like what you're already
doing is going to have an outsized
effect on what other people receive
right even though for you you've been
down that road many times but taking on
a new pursuit in parallel to that means
really getting excited about the
possibility you give the jim carrey
example about the possibility and
starting to imagine what that would
actually be like to be well let's say
fluent in spanish and you can just do
this reflexively without having to try
that's totally within your reach and i
think there it makes sense to really
think about the end point quite a lot as
a way to get over those barriers of sure
of fear because when you already know
how to do something there's no fear
barrier yeah it's just an energy barrier
right but when you're don't know how to
do something there's all this
sense of clunkiness that is really
uncomfortable beginner's mind is a
painful place that's so hard man a lot
of people think about it like beginner's
mind is such a you know it's such a
delightful place to be so hard the
friction the amount of energy to build
momentum is so challenging in the
beginning well this is where play
becomes very important because you know
the great physicist you know richard
feynman was also famous in addition to
being a you know physics phenom for
having the sense of play he learned a
bongo drum late in life he was became an
artist late in life and he had this
lightness and this and this kind of
joyful way to approach things humor at
oneself
is incredibly powerful now we know the
chemical basis for that laughing at
oneself is often the best
way to move forward really yeah because
you you i mean i do this well maybe i
don't know maybe i'm biased but i do
this all the time i'll just laugh at
myself for how worked up i can get about
the fact that a file won't load or
something like that i just laugh and
it's crazy i mean and all of a sudden i
have the energy to do it so what does
that do for our brain when we laugh at
ourself but not but there's probably a
difference between laughing ourselves or
something like that versus
making fun of something that's a bad
habit like
always shaming ourselves not shaming
ourselves
shame is kind of written into like who
we are it's not about what we're doing
it has this element of like who we are
you know guilt is sort of more about i
forget who said this but it wasn't me
first so i just want to be clear i
recognize it wasn't me first guilt is
sort of more about um
what we did
you know shame is is like an identity
thing
um laughing at ourselves yeah like
laughing ourselves like how ridiculous
the human mind can control i mean let's
face it as brilliant as as the
the nervous system and our minds and our
bodies can be they they make a lot of
mistakes
we are a fallible species we're not a
perfect
species and perfection should never be
the goal
can a person make it
so they never
get depressed they never react to
their perception their
people's actions towards them where they
never get to a state of uh i don't feel
good i'm feeling more depressed
i'm in a dark place now i'm stuck in
this place is there a way that we could
ever
defend ourselves against negative
stressors negative emotions or are we
just
are they do we need them as well to have
contrast in life well there's sort of
two views on this um i'll reveal mine
after i um sort of
explain the two views one is that
these states i guess i'm i'm
automatically calling things like
depression a state of mind
so when i say state of mind i mean brain
and body because your body is really
feeling
it's like the brain is connected to the
body right and so if you're saying
internally the thought of like i'm
depressed i don't feel good or i'm sad
or lonely or i'm not good enough the
body's going to react is that what i'm
understanding absolutely the body's
going to manifest what the mind is
telling you absolutely the thought the
idea you're going to be like i'm sad i'm
not good enough you're gonna shrink
right is that right that's right i mean
they're really two forms of depression
um sometimes they're intermixed but one
is anxiety-associated depression and you
you if you've ever experienced it or for
anyone that's experienced it they feel
agitation in their body
and their mind races but in their body
so the body is recruited
there are also depressive states
that people feel very fatigued and
exhausted it's been overwhelmed and they
also experience that in their body
the idea of getting out of bed in the
morning is hard um
motivating to exercise doing the sorts
of things that we know
are powerful for pushing back on
depression
so
the body is recruited i think most
people would say that
depressive states are bad when they
bring down the baseline on life i
just to as a brief aside anytime there's
a question about mental health or
addiction or trauma or anything
one could look at it and make up some
argument of low evolutionarily this
makes sense we all get depressed but
we have to be fair to the person
experiencing it of course and have
sensitivity that some behaviors will
keep the baseline of our life steady
meaning job relationships etc will
continue as they are other activities
will tend to improve the baseline on our
life job activities relationship etc
will will improve and then there's some
things like heroin which
does very quickly we can predict that
very quickly the baseline on life is
going to creep down regardless of who
that person is right so people say can
you get addicted to water well maybe but
i have to drink a lot of water before
the baseline of my life starts to go
down so sure it feels uncomfortable
that's just like man i'm so bloated
exactly so we tend to throw around
things like addiction and depression a
little loosely so yeah i think that it's
fair to say that depression is wired
into us as a possible state that we can
all fall into
but that it's very important in my
opinion
that humans have tools
to remove themselves from that state
of course to avoid your tragedies like
suicide but also because when the
baseline on someone's life goes down far
enough
they find it increasingly hard to do the
sorts of things that are going to get
them out of depression so you or i could
say so they stay in that state of
depression that's right it's too hard to
go work out it's too hard to change my
habit of eating healthier so i'm going
to stay
i'm going to keep eating ice cream which
is going to make my body
you know depressed that's right right if
i can keep eating bad foods if i keep
staying up till 4 a.m if i keep staying
in a toxic relationship i want to feel
depressed that's right and eventually
because of this very
um
inseparable relationship between the
brain and body eventually what happens
is that because the brain controls the
body but also the body can control the
brain
people lose the ability to intervene in
this depressive process so you or i
could say look
if someone who's depressed they what
they need to do is get up early get some
light in their eyes
get some movement i know you put this
information out there which i love
because these these those tips are
grounded
in uh they're not even tips they're
really tools and they're very powerful
because they're grounded in excellent
science you get that dopamine release
early in the day that's anti-depressive
you time your sleep better when you get
sun in your eyes and you get movement
early in the day
for most people that's accessible and
they should be they absolutely should be
doing it everyone should be doing that
but for people who are far enough down
that path of depression
because the body and the mind have this
relationship that's so close it there is
a crossover point where
they really can't do those activities
because they're so far deep into the
depression the body won't do what they
decide to do
and so now i'm not trying to give anyone
a pass because ultimately we are all
responsible for our own mental health
certainly
adults more than kids but you know we're
all responsible for our own mental
health and only we can direct our own
brain changes that's the that's the
stinger once we're you know 25 years and
older
we are the only ones that can change our
brain and we can talk about
neuroplasticity if you like but the
depressed person
has to take responsibility for their
behavior but this is why it's so
important to catch this brain-body
relationship early and build
routines that keep one out of depression
so that was a long path back to answer
your question succinctly i hope which is
we can stay out of depression but we
have to keep depression at bay by doing
things regularly there is something
called adrenal insufficiency syndrome
which is a real medical phenomenon where
the adrenals are incapable of making
these cortisol and adrenal hormones but
the the truth is that you have enough
adrenaline and cortisol in your body to
last two lifetimes and 25 famines i mean
we were built with a lot of robustness
right this explains you know that you
know the david goggins of the world they
they you know we we all do have that
greater capacity that people talk about
the stress is very misunderstood because
people think of stress as this ancient
carryover that's very unfortunate it
kind of gets lumped with depression like
oh this is just a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so
anytime you liberate adrenaline into
your bloodstream you also protect
yourself against infection of bacteria
and viruses because if you think about
if we had to gather food and we didn't
have it and we had to then pack up and
you know migrate long distances you
can't afford to get sick and this is why
people who work work work work and then
rest they usually get sick when they
finally stop and rest yeah it's like the
post finals phenomenon in university or
after the season
or a game or the caretaker thing where
you're taking care of somebody who's ill
and you're just
work work work or taking care of young
children and then you finally stop to
rest you go on vacation and you get
slammed with with what is that because
you're being in your comfort zone now
are you just a stress turned off and
adrenaline
so that these the stress response
recruits the immune
organs of the body to release killer t
cells in fact wim hof breathing i know
you're familiar with whim
of doing 20 or 30 deep inhales and
exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold is
known to stimulate adrenaline release
and the one of the better papers that's
out there scientific peer-reviewed
papers is a study published in the
pristine national academy of sciences
where they brought in two groups
one group
did wim hof breathing
the other group did just uh mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with e coli
right crazy right crazy it's crazy the
meditators got fever diarrhea and and um
and vomiting and the people who did wim
hof
either didn't get it or got it to a much
lesser extent sluggish but that's right
they didn't right this is not an
experiment to do at home isn't this
crazy but it makes perfect sense because
it inc that breathing simulates a stress
response it stimulates cortisol and
adrenaline which signals protects the
body right which signals to the thymus
the spleen and the other you know the
the nodes of the immune system to
liberate killer cells and so when that
bacteria comes in
the system is ready for it
your body is defending against viruses
that's right disease that's right
essentially
when you create a routine of healthy
stress that's right and and we can talk
about we definitely want to
you don't want stress on all the time
sleep is really important etc but that
stress response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells what's interesting about growth
mindset is that it seems like there's
some attachment of the reward systems of
the brain to the
action or the pursuit of a goal not just
achieving a goal and when we step back
and we look at
what that really entails at a
neurochemical level we have reward
systems in the brain they generally fall
into two categories they're the reward
systems that make you feel really good
with kind of the here and now and
everything that's within the confines of
your skin and the things you already
have you know love of your dog love of
your spouse
gratitude for all the things you happen
to have and that and those are generally
governed by the release of molecules
like serotonin and oxytocin okay
but then there's another reward system
which is the one that drove a lot of
human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
i'm going to work to this goal i'm going
to build my company i'm going to you
know get 10 years or press whatever it
is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards
now
the ability to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute game changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this cove you know pandemic
situation
the
but the amazing thing is remember the
brain only does five things and we get
to decide which of those sensations and
perceptions have relevance and which
ones don't or which ones are attached to
a goal and which ones aren't so growth
mindset in its purest form is the
attachment of these reward systems to
the effort process to the friction
process and not just to obtaining a
reward and just as a kind of final point
to that there's a very um well-known
body of literature and neuroscience at
least among neuroscientists that talks
about something called reward prediction
error and it says
if you can dose the dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too
where you're in real anticipation of
something this is going to be great this
is going to be great this can be great
and then you reach that goal and it's
kind of underwhelming and that generally
triggers this the circuit that i
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself i'm on the right track
this friction i'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good i'm going to tell myself this
is for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we're talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the
number of things you can do or the
energy to do them so just as a last last
point about dopamine when we're in
effort we're always secreting adrenaline
we're always in pursuit and it's
draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team is depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine i didn't have the power of
concentration i hadn't read all the good
books that gun high school students read
growing up i had to
learn how to speak properly i learned
how to learn how to think properly and
really learn how to
commit to something that was very linear
and at times was very painful and and i
went to some pretty extreme things i um
you know i actually used to
set a timer
uh and i wouldn't allow myself to get
out of the chair until i was the timer
went off right so and i would experience
extreme agitation but over time i got
pretty good and now i can do long stints
of work without any breaks i would hide
in the tower books section
uh in the evenings and i would read
everything about fitness psychology
anything i could i've always devoured
information my favorite book when i was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
guinness book of worlds records so i was
like when i was a little kid i'd walk
around the aspen center for physics and
i would tell anyone i didn't even ask
them if they wanted to hear about like
the what's the world's smallest
eutherian mammal you know i would like
it could tell you all these facts that
were kind of meaningless at the time but
um i've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different animals on the
planet and their different behaviors and
so
yeah voracious reader and still now
yeah i love i love information why why
fear why do we have fears why do we have
trauma why do we have shame and here's
the stinger it was all set up for you in
your youth i don't want to focus on the
bad but most of the stuff when you're
young you're just a passive learning
machine it's all coming in little kids
are learning three languages with no
accents flexibly they're not even
thinking about they're learning
instruments you know someone asked a
great question the other day at the
workshop wait now i know i want all that
stuff how come it's so much tougher and
there's a lot of biology i'd be happy to
tell you about that explains why that
all shuts down after these so-called
critical periods during development so
what happens when you're an adult and
you want to change your brain so now i'm
going to get into stuff that's that
hopefully is useful to you
okay so these basic facts that changing
your brain in a real way as an adult
requires that you
do particular things that activate
particular chemical systems in your
brain so how do you do that right i
could tell you all about the chemicals
and i'll tell you a little bit about
them but how do you do it okay so
this is a right here right now urgent
situation car wreck it's terrible you
can imagine any other trauma in its
place when that happens a little area in
the base of the brain the name isn't
important but if you care it's called
nucleus basalis
does its job which is just it's an alert
system it puts all its attention on
right here right now get everybody safe
it's your alert system and it has this
effect of dumping out
a certain chemical called acetylcholine
at specific locations in the brain that
are paired with that experience and
forever that experience will be
traumatic unless something else is done
okay so there's some nuance and some
details to this but that pretty much
summarizes it it's been replicated many
many times in dozens of studies you can
pair pretty much any experience with
stimulation of nucleus basalis this
thing in the in the base of the brain
and that experience will be mapped or
remapped in your brain as an adult and
that's remarkable it's also exciting
because then i someone like me says well
then how do i change my experience how
do i change the meaning of what happens
how do i change something from traumatic
to positive
the good news is nucleus basalis is just
a slave to whatever
is exciting traumatic it likes emotion
it like it likes peaks and lows and so
if acetylcholine is released that means
you can massively change your brain at
that moment with whatever's paired with
it and so when you get into a peak state
here you're jumping up and down or in a
really low state and you're thinking how
miserable something is you have to be
really careful because those are the
things that you're wiring in
all right so you can move to a state
like this about driving later if you
form enough associations with driving to
really eliminate to override the fear
you need to create a positive experience
in its place
so how do you do that
so i'm going to tell you that the way
you do that is not to think too hard and
to not verbalize things too much and
this is coming from someone who spent 25
years three times a week on a couch
letting subconscious things geyser up
and that's where i really learned that
it was really the things that you don't
realize that have the potential to have
the most impact but this power of
emotion the ability to couple really
strong emotions with things is so useful
if you want to change your brain for the
better and the way you do that
is clear in the physical space we all
know this story there are many news
cases like this woman's child stuck
under car super human strength
we heard a lot of amazing stories about
desperation jj's story was one of
desperation she's like no i'm not going
to accept
failure because failure in the case in
the case she was describing was
potentially the death of her child so
desperation is a strong one and it's
motivate motivated by fear but what if
you're not in a desperate state and you
really want to do something in that case
there's something remarkable and then we
should and we should ask ourselves why
are children such great passive learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play play
isn't just movement although it includes
movement it's giving things everything
you've got but keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all
strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills and he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got i'm
really glad you mentioned the diaphragm
diaphragm of course being this muscle
inside of all of us at least all mammals
that works all the time to move our
lungs because all the cells our body
need oxygen of course we get rid of
carbon dioxide it does that but it's
done reflexively but we can also take
voluntary control over it i want to just
mention about the diaphragm why it's so
important for what were these state
changes is that a lot of people talk
about the vagus nerve and all this stuff
the vagus and these connections between
the brain and this vagus nerve or the
gut
it's what gets activated when you're
really full and you eat a big meal and
you feel relaxed those are great but
it's very slow
the diaphragm is skeletal muscle just
like your bicep just like your tricep
just like your quadricep it is the only
internal organ except maybe a couple
muscles in your throat that are actually
skeletal muscle meaning it was designed
to be voluntarily moved
and the diaphragm isn't just designed to
move your lungs it also sends a signal
through the so-called phrenic nerve back
to the brain to inform your brain about
the status of your body so when you
breathe fast deliberately the reason you
feel kind of an elevated sense of
alertness is because the other chemicals
secrete but mostly because the phrenic
nerve is firing off it's telling you hey
the body's moving we're really running
now even though you're stationary in a
chair if you're doing breathing or if
you're breathing very slowly and
rhythmically right box type breathing or
you know slow slow breathing your
diaphragm is telling your brain hey
we're calm we're good and you calm down
very quickly on the order of seconds and
so once you start tapping into this you
start realizing okay movement of the
body was designed to inform the brain of
where to be not just the brain telling
the body and how does the body
communicate with the brain through the
phrenic nerve from the diaphragm so my
lab is really pursuing two questions and
this is still being worked out so i just
want to highlight that it's still in
progress
but
certain patterns of breathing will calm
you very much like entering a hypnotic
state and so you have a subset of
neurons in your brain stem that are
responsible for sighing is it you have a
subset of neurons in your brainstem
responsible for for coughing subset of
neurons responsible for laughter and a
subset of neurons in your brain stem for
sign this was a paper published in
nature this is a real thing these
neurons are every so often and your dog
does this too
you inhale
twice
and then you exhale long
now that double inhale
best done through the nose on the
inhales and then long exhale through the
mouth
activates these side neurons that
trigger the so-called calming reflex the
parasympathetic arm of the nervous
system
so we have a hard-wired mechanism a set
of neurons connection in the diaphragm
and back again from the diaphragm to the
brain that was designed to activate calm
and when people ask me how should i
breathe to calm myself down i always say
double inhale through the nose followed
by exhales two or three of those will
reset your autonomic nervous system
faster than any other mechanism we're
aware of
because it's really capitalizing on a
set of neural circuits now once you're
calm you say well how do i get into
plasticity states there you want to go
the other direction
that's going to be inhaling a lot more
than you exhale you're going to be
driving in more oxygen than you are
breathing out
generally carbon dioxide and that will
lead to states that are kind of more
elevated this is typical of things like
tumor breathing wim hof breathing
kundalini breathing and when people
enter those states
their whole world changes because it
shuts off the frontal cortex it really
this is why sometimes people pass out or
they feel like they want to get up and
move you know you get some odd behavior
when you're doing this kind of thing
so the key is if you want to access
states of heightened plasticity let's
say you want to learn faster or you want
to be more
you want to bring more out of some
physical training that you're doing the
key is to apply those principles first
you need to focus you need to bring
yourself to that heightened state of
alertness you can breathe to do that so
this would be super oxygenated breathing
then you want to drop into a state of
calm and you do that by these a couple
maybe two or three rounds of inhale
inhale exhale inhale inhale exhale and
then now your brain is in a state we
believe this is still again being worked
out in labs like mine and david's that
then you're in a state for heightened
learning
because you're in a state where
neurochemicals like acetylcholine are
going to be at levels that are higher
than they typically would be things like
noradrenaline slightly higher than they
typically would be but not in a
discombobulated way in a very regulated
way and the cool thing is you're
regulating them so you could argue you
know earlier we were talking about
subjective emotions and thoughts and all
these things but one thing that's
absolutely concrete is breathing i
always think of physical exercise
movement writing whatever singing
dancing talking those are physical
actions in the universe
then you have thoughts and somewhere in
between those is controlling your
respiration once you can control
everything that's within the confines of
your skull and skin once you can really
control that relationship that brain
body relationship you start to realize
that relationship is a lot like any
other relationship to forward action
it's just all happening within the
confines of my body so it's heightened
states of focus followed by states of
relaxation that are going to prime your
nervous system for learning and
plasticity just like hypnosis
hashtag growth mindset is one of the
most popular hashtags in social media
but most people don't actually know what
it means and again this is carol dweck's
discovery not mine it was discovered in
a group of kids that were doing math
problems or other kinds of puzzles that
they knew they couldn't get right but
they enjoyed doing them and they perform
exceedingly well on lots of sorts of
tests of that sort
when there is the right answer of course
and so what they do is they somehow
they're wired for effort they're wired
for the puzzle not for the solution and
when i say puzzle i don't mean the noun
puzzle i mean the verb for being puzzled
it for them feels good and so we need to
think uh if we're talking about the
nervous system and we want to make it
actionable for high performance whether
or not it's in business or sport or
otherwise we want to think in terms of
processes not events and verbs not nouns
so growth mindset as a verb as an action
item you know
reward as a verb not just as oh you're
going to just pat yourself on the back
like it's no it's what you internalize
it's a process
that's how the neural circuits that
underlie reward get stronger and the
beauty of of the brain is that you have
this thing of neural plasticity which is
its ability to change itself throughout
the whole lifespan and the more you
practice this the better you get at it
and it does not mean you're walking
around talking delusionally about how
great life is when everything is
terrible it means you might even be very
stoic you might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to continue to push
forward dopamine is not just about
reward it's one of the biggest
misconceptions dopamine is about
motivation
and drive it's like a jet that propels
you along a path how do we get more
dopamine you practice subjectively
releasing dopamine in your mind like wow
okay so
that's a great question first of all
there are ways you can get more dopamine
release through thoughts or through
drugs or through supplements i want to
be really clear there is a drug there
are two drugs actually that will cause
massive release of dopamine they're
called cocaine and methamphetamine
the problem gets us addicted because it
feels so good the problem is exactly the
problem is cocaine and methamphetamine
stimulate so much dopamine release
that the
drug becomes the only source it becomes
the goal of your path it becomes the
path and the destination and you look at
people's lives when they do a lot of
cocaine and methamphetamine and that
baseline on their life goes down
dopamine is this incredibly powerful
molecule that allows us to buffer the
effort process it allows us to be an
effort longer and it allows us to
actually eventually enjoy the process of
effort and not think about the reward
but just say oh i'm enjoying the process
right well you just described the first
step the first step in learning to
attach dopamine to the effort process
which is the key
operation in order to succeed
is to
be very careful about how much you focus
on the end goal keeping the goal in mind
is important for like a proper
orientation you have to know the
ultimate destination but if at any point
we were to evaluate our progress
relative to that end goal
or if we don't know what the end goal is
there's a huge gap there and it can feel
overwhelming the key to this is if we
want to be very concrete we should
probably focus on actions and i'll use
fitness as an example because it
translates to everybody whereas you know
people's circumstances is different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the behavior pleasureful
and to give you energy the key is to
subjectively reward those steps so it's
not going to be let's say i go out and i
run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mild the hard part you want to
tell yourself
this is the good part this is the part
that gives me energy and i'll be very
surprised if people don't actually feel
like they could continue further so it's
a journey of a thousand miles starts
with a single is made up of you know
single steps but the key is to reward
the harder steps not the easier ones and
not the ones where you get the thing
that you want there's a process i'm
going through right now where i'm trying
to write a book and um it's hard and
it's hard and i was told that the harder
it is the better i'm probably doing it
and i was like great and my editor's
ready to kill me and because i'm slow
and i and i know and i'm a very slow
person i i drive people crazy i'm like
glacially slow because science is slow
and i like to get things right i want to
rush it i like to get things right but
i'm very proud of the fact that
everything we've published i can stand
behind it was the best we could do with
the tools at the time and i just know
that when i look back on a writing
career or a scientific career i want to
be able to say you know every journal we
put it in was rock solid everything was
rock solid we had fun doing it the
relationship so i go slow yeah but as a
consequence what i'm finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days i'm i'm i think social media is
great i teach neuroscience on social
media because i think it's important to
do public education
too but it's incredible and it's it's
incredible how much time and energy it
can take so what i've started doing now
is i turn off my phone and i lock it in
a safe
and i experience extreme anxiety right
it's so weird why is that is it because
it gives you so much dopamine that when
you're not having it well this is scary
because i actually think um brief
anecdota on the weekend i was driving
there's a kid that i mentor and i picked
up my phone and i was texting while i
was driving and he said to me this was
really embarrassing for me he said
you know
i wish you wouldn't text while you drive
and i put it and i put it down and i
realized this is crazy i know that i
that my life in his life is far more
important
and the lives of the people around me
are far more important than any text
message which means i wasn't doing it
rationally it's just pure reflex at this
point so i would i don't think i pick up
the phone because i'm i don't even know
what i'm looking for there anymore it's
just become reflexive so
for me lately
the longer i can keep that phone in a
safe and right on a grant or my or this
book
what i tell myself is the agitation is
good i'm it's at least i'm not doing
that
and then i find that as i start to write
and i
get into the process i start feeling
good about it and i'll pause and say
okay i i have control i have ultimate
control over my behavior i can put that
thing away there might be a nuclear war
out there and
i'm just doing this anyway i have
control over my thoughts my feelings and
behavior so i tell myself that and then
i find i have immense energy and all i
want to do is write and i kind of tunnel
into the process wow and i think that
sometimes people need to write these
things out for themselves so it's really
concrete i think some people are so
unskilled at subjective rewards that
writing it out is really powerful so
what would you write out for yourself as
a subjective reward for this experience
as long as i'm writing i'm on the right
path
as long as i'm not writing and looking
at my phone i'm not on the right path
because for me the the two or three
things that are most important for my
career are writing grants working on
this book manuscript and writing
scientific manuscripts i mean there are
other things as well anything else that
you're not doing is is holding you back
from doing that that's right so you need
to be focused center mass forward on
doing those things that's right so i
don't do any jumping around power poses
things like that i will
use tools to kind of ramp up my dope i
mean there are certain songs that are
really embedded in my emotionally my
emotional thing that go back to you know
when i was a you know
while you know skateboarding punk rock
teenager that will get me fired up and i
think there's real utility that's pure
dopamine there's an interesting process
that
um that occurs when people start to
realize that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control
this idea of duration path and outcome
and attach an internal sense of reward
just that you're doing well to reward
yourself mentally just say i'm doing
well i'm actually on the right path
to do that
inside of the
demands that come from the external
world the more often that we can
self-reward
some aspect of the process provided it's
in the right direction of what we're
trying to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more focus we're going to have
for that and remember that nor the
reason i say energy i don't throw that
around loosely is that
limiting amount of noradrenaline is
constantly being kept at bay you're
literally buffering the quit response
and so when people start realizing that
if they set the goals inside of the
larger goal and self-reward each one of
those they essentially have an infinite
amount of energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most
in the special operations community and
people that are selected essentially for
this process so one of the things that's
been intriguing to me i have some
friends from the seal teams and i don't
begin to you know really understand the
real work that they do deployed because
i've never done that kind of work but
i've always been intrigued by the
selection process the so-called buds
process right because
carrying logs and
getting in cold water and all that
that's not really how
the work is that's really not what the
work is about so the selection process
is interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit i mean i think like
there might be a couple to show up to
show up but everybody is absolutely
convinced and then a very small subset
of them make it through
and i'd be willing to bet that the ones
that make it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's
a reward process maybe it's through
self-punishment maybe it's through
self-reward um in the positive sense but
they're able to control something inside
an environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors and
i've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to
not in order to get through you just
have to not quit remember people aren't
being deselected they're not saying get
out of here you're not good enough
you're not people are deciding that for
themselves
and so it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and i believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters
and the people when i say manage i think
that the people that get through knowing
some of these people quite well
had an internal process by which they
could reward themselves for doing
something that might have just looked
trivial to everybody else but it gave
them more gas more energy right right
and what's interesting is the process
the kind of unconscious genius of of the
buds process is that
they've picked two sensory events
that are
across the board challenging for
everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you
right it's not like heat which can kill
you it's cold water and sleep
deprivation and so the ability to do
these like what i'm calling dpos this uh
duration path and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know i you know when
you have a when you're well fed well
slept you can do anything you can be in
any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is
these deep reserves of the nervous
system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us
pay more attention to how we feel than
the demands of the world around us
remember that yeah basic challenge in
the nervous system and so sleep
deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because
it's very easy again rested to do all
this but so what they do is they're
sleep deprived people they put them in
cold water they're trying to get them
more in touch with the way that they
feel inside than what they need to do in
response to the external demands right
everyone i know that's made it through
that process did it slightly differently
but i'll tell you how they didn't do it
they didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by
micro
slicing the day or slicing the day into
a series of meals that they just need to
get to and then rewarding themselves for
getting to that next milestone so they
don't know i mean most of them
you know probably had very low concept
of dopamine and norepinephrine but
that's the process that's also the
process i think that allows someone to
finish an ultra i've never run an ultra
but i think that process of self-reward
is
grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and i
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and i think it's therefore i think
it's it's so key because i think people
think that
uh it's just so key that people
understand excuse me that these circuits
are not unique
to people who run ultras or people that
make it through
uh you know stringent filter special
operations command
it's the same thing that it is
interesting an ability to control your
levels of stress in real time is
extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down this creates more space in your
thoracic cavity and your heart actually
gets a little bit bigger
as a consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down
a signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up
in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity as a consequence
blood flows more quickly through that
smaller volume the sinoatrial node
registers that and sends a signal to
your brain
and the brain sends a signal to slow the
heart down so in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up exhaling slows
your heart rate down so if you want to
speed up your heart rate and be more
alert inhale more or make those inhales
more vigorous more intense
if you want to calm down
you can do that quickly by making your
exhales slightly longer than your
inhales or making them more vigorous
this doesn't require any breath work
this is something that you can do in
real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase it's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
hrv but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time i'm a big fan of wellness and
and i think it's a great community but
it tends to run in absolutes and there
and there aren't a lot of operational
definitions as we say in science and i
what i love about your questions you're
asking for
really getting to the meat of things
asking for the operational definitions
one of the most dangerous ideas in
wellness and in popular psychology is
that your body hears every thought you
have what a terrible thing to put on
people you know what wow what a
challenging thing i don't think people
should try and suppress their negative
thoughts i think there is great value
however to introducing positive thought
schemes now the reason is not because i
think it's just because i think so but
because there's actually a neurochemical
basis
for controlling stress and actually
making stress more tolerable and
extending one's ability to be in bouts
of effort and that relates to the
dopamine pathway
so the molecule dopamine is a reward
it's
released in the brain when you win a
game you you close a deal
the great love of your life you complete
something
but
most of our dopamine release is not from
achieving goals it's actually released
when we are enroute to our goals we're
in pursuit of our goals and we think
we're on the right path this is what
people from elite special forces can do
they know how to make small
simple
physical steps in the real world
that allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
horizon in very close and so
if you can move the horizon to something
you know you can complete and you reward
that
you essentially are where you were
before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external but
the ability to control these internal
reward schedules is everything to what
extent does our subjective narrative the
story the story we tell ourselves
actually means something for the body
and to what extent does the body
actually mean something for the
subjective narrative so
this gets into some areas of work that
we're doing now and so i do want to
highlight that it's ongoing work but i
think
you know the old narrative meaning a few
10 years ago was that if you're feeling
depressed just smile well if that worked
right we would have a lot less
depression than we see out right the
reason i call it a brain body contract
early on is that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so
you know the idea that when we're
depressed we tend to be in more
defensive type postures when we're
feeling good we tend to be in more like
relaxed and extended postures all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that i'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going and how do
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective
there is one way in which subjective
thought and deliberate thought is very
powerful over states of mind and body to
answer your question can you think your
way out of the ice bath being cold so a
couple things that are important first
of all just to
go a little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but
thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now
i can say
okay have a thought
that um just decide to write your name
and your you can do that i'm going to
decide to write my name and you can do
it so that's a deliberate thought which
says that you can introduce thoughts so
i think it's very hard to control
negative thoughts directly by trying to
suppress them
they ten generally they tend to just
want to continue to geyser up all the
time
but we can introduce a positive thought
acetylcholine is the neurochemical that
we want to think about anytime we're
talking about neural plasticity and in
particular attention high attentional
states so everyone knows that the brain
is very plastic early in life so from
birth until about age 25 you can learn
so much for better or for worse i always
say the downside is that early in life
you're you have less control over your
life circumstances but your brain is
very plastic so there's a you know dark
and light to that later in life you have
a lot more control generally over your
life circumstances but the brain becomes
less plastic however
we know based on nobel prize winning
work and
recent work in addition to that
that the
neuromodulator acetylcholine is secreted
when we pay attention to something very
specific it acts as sort of a spotlight
in the brain making certain synapses the
connections between neurons more active
and more likely to be active again than
others so when you hear that song that
you love so much and it moves you and
you feel dopamine being pulsed into your
body that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you form that
deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially wired
in a very indelible way into your
nervous system multiple you can probably
even with certain songs you can feel
your body start to energize because of
course the brain
through connections with your muscles
controls your body
so
for things that are traumatic or
negative what we're really talking about
is neuroplasticity that's focused on
unlearning and most of the therapies for
this whether or not it's emdr eye
movement desensitization reprocessing or
it's traditional psychoanalysis and
psychotherapy or it's somatic embodied
release big you know kundalini breathing
type almost all of those are designed to
do something which is to bring the
person or you bring yourself
into a state of heightened alertness
right you can't do this stuff when
you're sort of half asleep heightened
alertness and then focusing your
attention on the traumatic or negative
event this is the way that it works and
then pairing that was something new you
know traditionally this was done with
things like nlp or in talk therapy where
people would feel
the relation the positive relationship
with the therapist that was kind of the
main rationale
in association with this very traumatic
sometimes even you know shameful type
events and the idea is that you you
would simultaneously have those two
experiences the negative one and the
feeling of safety and you would rewire
those circuitries i actually believe
that can work but it can take
a lot of times it can take a lot of
visits to the therapist which is not to
say it's bad it's just not everyone has
access to those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out
that somehow when people recount these
traumatic experiences when they're doing
these lateralized eye movements not
vertical eye movements they
somehow
separate out the negative emotions and i
thought for years people would ask me
about this stuff tom and i thought this
is ridiculous first of all i'm a vision
scientist and i work on stress it's like
there's no way and then i really ate my
words because four papers two in humans
two in mice and then a fifth paper
published in nature which is kind of our
super bowl of scientific publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of
when the way that we view the visual
world when we move through space when
our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements
are what happens when you move forward
in space when you're walking when you're
moving forward towards something and
that suppresses
activation of the amygdala now you say
why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there
was actually graduates in my laboratory
where we're looking at fear in this case
we're looking at fear to big looming
objects that either trigger freezing or
running and hiding there's a brain area
that's in your brain and my brain that
mice also have that triggers a third
option not run and hide not freeze but
forward confrontation this is the no i'm
gonna fight i'm gonna move forward in
the face of diversity this is the growth
mindset i'm going to lean into friction
and it turns out that this circuit is
linked to the dopamine reward pathway
when we move forward
in the face of a threat and obviously we
want to do this in healthy adaptive ways
we suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with emdr because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive eye
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space
so to make this a little more succinct
it's really forward movement action
pushing yourself across that threshold
not only rewards you but it suppresses
activity of the fear centers in the
brain and these are ancient hardwired
mechanisms these aren't hacks these are
things that mother nature installed in
us
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there